the Trump administration is laying out
details of its tough new strategy on
immigration a senior administration
official says the White House wants the
right to detain migrant children longer
and make it harder for asylum seekers to
get work permits new government figures
show more than one hundred and three
thousand people were apprehended at the
us-mexico border in March more than 92
thousand of them were between ports of
entry major garrett is at the white
house major good morning good morning
the White House driven by reelection
impulses sees two possible outcomes one
the president's hardline immigration
policies make matters worse more
apprehensions more detentions more
suffering and Congress seeing all this
is forced to act or Congress does
nothing the president campaigns against
beltway gridlock and democratic
resistance all while keeping immigration
and border security politically alive we
have the worst laws of any country
anywhere in the world the president is
leaning hard right and seeking
re-election daylight in a now-deleted
video on Twitter mr. Trump turns the
table on race and immigration
positioning Trump supporters as victims
of biased elites they want open borders
they want to have millions of people
pouring into our country according to
senior officials the president is
looking to increase spending on larger
detention facilities without
congressional approval we're bucking a
court system that never ever rules for
us and we're bucking really bad things
with Congress forced resignations
continue at Homeland Security and a deep
sense of unease has gripped the agency
suddenly seen as a hotbed of nevertrump
resistance by White House adviser a new
immigration point man Stephen Miller I'm
very concerned about Stephen Miller's
role in immigration policy Miller and
the White House according to sources are
reviewing all options at the border
including family separation President
Obama separated children they had child
separation I was the one that changed it
the president falsely compared his
family separation policy to that of
former President Obama both
administrations used it mr. Trump did so
aggressively while mr. Obama rarely
separated families once you don't have
it that's why you see many more people
coming they're coming like
it's a picnic because let's go to
Disneyland secretary Nielsen's last day
as the head of the Department of
Homeland Security is today and summoners
inner circle are expected to leave with
her Customs and Border Protection head
Kevin McAllen and takes over today and
it is not clear here if he's going to be
the permanent successor as the White
House reviews its options Gayle members
in Congress and within the agency look
at this turmoil with a growing sense of
alarm great we're following it too thank
you very much major